et on commence tout de suite premier
titre la prise de parole de volodymyr
zelensky c'était ce matin en amont du
discours de vladimir poutine
reste aux
pauvres aux new yorkais maputo
effectivement dans un clip posté ce
matin sur les réseaux sociaux on
découvre le chef de l'état ukrainien qui
marche dans kiev et y s'exprime ou face
caméra pendant près de cinq minutes en
réponse aux cérémonies russe organisée
ce lundi 9 mai pour célébrer la fin de
la seconde guerre mondiale il évoque à
grand renfort d'image de parade
militaire ukrainienne l'anniversaire de
l'indépendance de son pays mais il
rappelle également que les ukrainiens
ont aussi lutter contre le nazisme et
accuse vladimir poutine de répéter les
mêmes crimes un
paradoxe
vous venez vite pour cela être sauna 80
euros par hadopi tchèque veut trouver
un nouveau boulot
et augusto
il est celui qui répète aujourd'hui les
crimes horribles du régime hitlérien
suivant la philosophie nazis confiant ce
qu'ils ont fait en conséquence il permet
à tous et très vite nous célébrerons
deux jours de la victoire en ukraine et
certains n'ont plus qu'un seul nous les
vaincrons alors nous gagnerons nous
aussi et kiev vers à la parade de la
victoire
rennes victorieuse célébrant la victoire
sur le nazisme falloir à l'ukraine du
président zelensky dont une intervention
est prévue en france ce mercredi 11 mai
à 13h il s'adressera en direct pendant
60 minutes aux étudiants de plusieurs
universités françaises comme sciences po
l'inalco paris 1 panthéon sorbonne il
répondra également aux questions des
étudiants cet échange sera diffusée en
ligne sur le dos de notre 7 euros
pour le
modèle
38 pour revenir aux commémorations de la
fin de la seconde guerre mondiale ce
lundi l'ambassadeur russe en pologne a
été aspergée d'une substance rouge est
pris à partie par des manifestants pro
ukrainien il déposait une gerbe au
cimetière de varsovie en hommage aux
soldats soviétiques lorsqu'il a été pris
à partie doro stosur no 7 couvent une
très mauvaise photo vv ni trépané dire
bonsoir aussi touché au crâne
fracturé
le crâne est aussi au coeur des
discussions ce lundi au parlement
européen puisque nous célébrons
aujourd'hui la journée de l'europe dans
son discours le président français qui
assure jusqu'au mois de juin la
présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne a rappelé son soutien à
l'ukraine dénoncer les crimes commis par
les russes qu'ils seront poursuivis et
évoqué son espoir d'une fin rapide du
conflit
aucune attaque au centre de secours
de
swisstopo
pour que cette guerre prenne fin nous
avons adopté deux chopes savina à
kinshasa providers
simplement les sources de financement de
la star au covan
finance souveraine
photo
jean escodo entre nice
et enfin pour terminer cette information
pratique les réfugiés ukrainien
bénéficiant de la protection temporaire
vont pouvoir suivre jusqu'à 400 heures
de français à compter de ce lundi une
évaluation décidera de leur répartition
par niveau objectif leur permettent de
maîtriser les bases de la langue
française pour pouvoir notamment
envisager une activité professionnelle
il n'a pris qu'une si une formation
d'acteur au kenya comme date de notre
sueur de notre front
national avait
voté
automotrices les grosses poutres du
matin
merci merci